[Music]
on october 4th
2020 epidemiologists from harvard oxford
and stanford authored the great
barrington declaration
because of grave concerns about the
damaging physical and mental health
impacts of the prevailing covet 19
policies
they argued that all coveted 19
lockdowns should end
instead we should adopt a strategy they
call focus protection
which is aimed at protecting elderly and
vulnerable populations while allowing
everyone else to resume
normal life the proponents of focused
protection
say it's the most compassionate approach
to minimize mortality and social harm
until we reach herd immunity which is
the goal of all coveted 19 mitigation
strategies
this is the saner approach the more
moral approach more scientifically based
approach
critics of the declaration issued a
counter-memorandum
stating that any pandemic management
strategy relying upon immunity from
natural
infections for covet-19 is flawed
uncontrolled transmission
in younger people risk significant
morbidity and mortality across the whole
population
should the coronavirus lockdowns be
lifted and replaced with a targeted
strategy
that protects the old and other
high-risk groups that was the subject of
an
online soho forum debate on sunday
december 13th
it featured martin koldorf a harvard
biostatistician
and epidemiologist and co-author of the
great barrington
declaration versus andrew neumer an
associate professor
of population health and disease
prevention at university of california
irvine who signed the so-called jon snow
memorandum
written in response here's martin
kaldorf and andrew neumer in an online
debate
moderated by soho forum director gene
epstein
martin you're first up to defend the
resolution
you have 17 and a half minutes uh
jane please close the initial vote
and take it away martin thank you gene
um
the way we have approached the kobe 19
pandemic
is the worst public health disaster
ever the lockdowns and contact racing
strategy that has been employed by most
countries
have led to many excess unnecessary
deaths
both from kovi 19 as well as
from other health outcomes and
it's very tragic and it's a tragedy
on a worldwide scale
the failures can be split into two
one is we have failed to properly
protect
the high-risk older people among us
which have left two unnecessary deaths
in korvi 19.
also there has been enormous collateral
damage
from the lockdowns as well as from the
fear
that's associated with the lockdowns
and
that has caused a lot of damage for
younger people
and that's something that we
are going to have to live with and die
with for many years to come
even if the lockdowns would end tomorrow
now among the professionals
like uh lawyers or journalists or or
scientists like me
[Music]
things satan are quite okay there has
not been
uh as many many deaths as much mortality
among our group
on the other hand these lockdowns and
this strategy that we use for the
pandemic
has been the worst assault on the
working class
in half a century in the united states
the worst since segregation
and the vietnam war so
and and especially it has hurt uh
urban working class and the inner cities
so again uh very very tragic uh but
uh and and and while it has affected
everybody
it has uh especially affected the
working class
so the question is uh what really what
went wrong what happened here
uh well one thing that went wrong was
that most western countries had
prepared uh pandemic preparedness plans
beforehand
before this year started because we knew
as epidemiologists that
sooner or later there will be another
pandemic and after this one there will
be many more pandemics
because that's part of human history
so we knew they were going to come but
when
kovate 19 came at the beginning of this
year
most countries threw these pandemic
preparedness
out the window and
there were four fundamental
mistakes that we made that we
ignored basic public health principles
one is that in public health we cannot
look only at one disease corey 19.
in public health we always have to look
at health as a whole
so other diseases general health and
by looking at by focusing on corey 19
and ignoring other things
and the collateral damage cost and other
diseases
we have done a lot of disservice to
public health
and thrown that
that principle away a second principle
that we have ignored is
in public health one has to look at the
long term
and not the short term
if you're a cancer patient you want to
prolong life another six month or 12
months you look at it short term because
that way um your grandmother or
grandfather if they can live another
year
that's great for for for the family and
they can spend more time with children
and grandchildren and so on
but to postpone things in public health
to postpone
epidemic or pandemic that just pushes
the same priority into the future
so in in public health we have to think
of it long term
not short term
the third one is we have to look at the
whole population and not only
some parts of the population public
health means health for everybody
old and young rich and poor
urban rural etc and that has been
ignored during this process pandemic
and the fourth principle that we have
throughout the window is risk
communication
and with that of course the trust
between the population and public health
officials which has deteriorated
enormously
and which is going to be a big problem
for the future
so i'm going to go through a little bit
of each of these four uh in turn
before i do that there are things we
know more and more about kobe 19.
there are still things we do not know
but one thing we knew all
already from the very beginning uh from
from the winter and beginning of this
year
is that there is an enormous difference
in risk
between ages so while anybody can
get infected by this disease by kobe 19
and and all ages do get infected
the risk for for mortality is very
different so there's a
more than a thousand-fold risk a
difference in risk between the oldest
and the youngest so for all people
uh in their 70s and 80s and 90s and also
somewhere in the 60s
kobe 19 is a disease that's worse than
the annual influencer more serious more
dangerous
on the other hand for children
this is not a serious disease
it's much less for children there's much
less risk from kobe 19 than there is
from
the annual influenza
and there are many other health issues
that are
much more serious for children so uh
that's something that we should have
taken into account
when we uh when we devised a strategy
for how to deal with
this disease and we call that
in what we wrote in october with two
colleagues the great parental
declaration where we advocate for focus
protection where we
do better job at protecting the high
risk all people
at the same time as we let younger
people
live lives more normally they should
still do general
preventive measures like washing hands
and staying home and sick
but they should be able to live normal
lives to keep the society going
to avoid all the collateral damage from
the lockdowns
because that's the highest risk factor
for them they are much much higher risk
from these
lockdowns than from from kovitt
uh and uh so that's why we wrote the
great parenting declaration in october
which i did uh together with
two colleagues uh one is dr schneider
gupta at oxford university
who uh in my view is the preeminent
infectious technologist in the world
as well as dr jay baracharya from
stanford university
who is an expert on on inefficiency
technology
and how how public health policy affects
the most vulnerable
among us so
i want to go back a little bit to the
four principles and we start then with
the fact that we cannot focus on one
disease we have to focus
on uh on all health
so what has uh what are the collateral
damage
from from these lockdowns well
it has been devastating for children who
have not been allowed
many who have not been allowed to go to
schools
um and that's not only important for the
education and and
uh it's also important for their
physical health and their mental health
and it's important for
social development and
the effects are of course in in
short term right now but also long term
if you lose one year of education
of school that has long-term effects
on both your general education
as well as on long-term health effects
at the same time children are not at
risk themselves so they are
we are asking the children to sacrifice
themselves
uh for something that
even has almost zero benefits
and you would say that then well maybe
there's very few
children who got kobe 19 because there
were no schools
so to look at that what the effect is of
school closings on children we have to
look at
if you want to be scientific about it we
have to look at the one western country
who did not close to schools during the
height of the pandemic
in the spring and that was sweden so in
sweden daycare and schools were open
for all children ages 1 to 15 throughout
the height of the pandemic
when there was a lot of transmission in
society
and among among the 1.8 million children
in sweden
at this time there were exactly zero
covered 19 deaths so not a single
child that died from cover 19 in sweden
during this time
even though the schools were open
and this was done there was no testing
in the schools no testing with
children's
there were no masks used and there were
no social distancing
if a child was sick had a cough or a
sneezing or
or runny nose they were asked to stay at
home and if they came to school they
were sent home
so and there were also extra cleanings
in the schools but
that was the preventative measures and
despite that there were
no a single uh kovi 19 death there were
a few hospitalizations but not a single
death
and if we look at the teachers because
they are
also in schools the t-shirt had the same
like kov 19 risk as the average of other
professions so
they are not at excess risk because they
they deal with children all day and if
we look at multi-generational homes
uh if you were over 17 which case your
tire is for coverage
you had a higher risk if you lived with
working at adults compared to
adults your own age but
if you also lived with children that
didn't decrease the risk any further
so all the people in multinational homes
they are at excess risk but not from
children
but they are from the adults living in
the same home
and we can also see for children like
the vaccination rates have plummeted
because of the lockdowns
and it has recovered a little bit but
not fully and we have seen in some parts
of the world that we have had for
example measles outbreaks now
and there might be more to come most
likely
there are other health outcomes that has
been devastated by the
by the lockdowns
either because appointments are
cancelled or because people are afraid
to go to the hospitals
or they think the hospitals are full and
so on so the
cardiovascular disease outcomes as
worsens like heart attacks and strokes
and so on
so that has led to many excess deaths
um we have also cancer uh many uh
there's fewer cancers this year and you
would think that that would be a good
thing
because we don't like cancer five
minutes five minutes yeah
yeah yeah so uh
and nobody's gonna die from very few
people are gonna die from cancer this
year
because they don't have their screening
but uh
they are they are less cancers diagnosed
but there are still cancers there but
they're just detected later
so there is uh and then you get the
treatment later
so somebody maybe who didn't get the pap
smear screening
a woman might not die from cervical
cancer three or four years from now
instead of living 15 to 20 years
more so these are things that we're
going to see in the future
they also cause mental health and
there's uh
and in the third world in the developing
world uh
the consequences has been devastating
with children starving to death because
of the lockdowns
and while the politicians are excused
from
not uh thinking about their own
jurisdiction i think
as academics as scientists and public
health scientists
we don't have that excuse we have to
also think about
the rest of the world and the enormous
damage that happened in africa asia and
latin america because of lockdowns there
one example of this uh consequence of
the lockdown is if we look at the
those who are 25 to 44 years old in in
the u.s
among the deaths in the u.s so far in
this age group about 4
have been due to kovi 19 but the excess
mortality in this ace group is 26
according to a recent cdc study
published in
mmwr so that sort of shows the effect
of of the lockdowns on mortality in this
age group
uh and we don't know so yet exactly
which if it's cardiovascular or mental
health
issues like suicide or so on we don't
have those numbers yes but we know
it is enormous
so again uh
what uh even if these lockdowns end up
tomorrow
if you need to get back to normal
tomorrow
these are consequences of the
of the strategy of the lockdown and
contact trade station that has
failed to prevent older people from uh
from dying from kobe 19 at the same time
that generated enormous damage
on other disease outcomes and we've only
seen some of that
so far we're going to see much more of
that in the years to come
and we will also know the numbers
eventually so it will be very
clear now many of the numbers are not
there but we will eventually
have the the health statistics to uh
to be able to quantify that in greater
detail
so thank you very much that was my
initial remark
okay all right thank you you came in
under your allotment uh but uh you know
that uh
we don't we don't trade allotments uh
andrew neumer
speaking for the negative uh take it
away andrew thank you very much
gene thank you for uh having me thank
you to everyone at the soho forum for
inviting me and for hosting this event
thank you for the audience for uh for
watching uh both uh
live and i assume this will be available
on youtube or something later on so
thank you for joining us and
and thank you to martin for uh for
agreeing to be uh
the opponent today and uh if you want to
uh
see uh what i feel about this ongoing
epidemic as the crisis evolves i'm on uh
i'm active on twitter
you can follow me or block me at
andrew neumer uh i have
uh no uh financial conflicts of interest
to report uh
so uh a number of people in my
profession discouraged me from uh
joining this debate today um
but i i just want to say that uh
academic freedom and rational discourse
is a hill that i
will die that i'm willing to die on so
i think it's important for us to have an
open exchange
of ideas and to let the public
who are after all stakeholders in all of
this uh see both sides of the debate so
even though i have very strong feelings
uh about the topic of the day i'm really
glad to have this opportunity to engage
in some with someone who thinks
otherwise
this uh this debate has become extremely
polarized
and most of you are probably tuning in
uh to to watch two scientists sort of
talk past one another
and so that you can cheer on the the
decide that you have already
um made up your mind on but i hope uh
nonetheless that
you will engage with this material in an
open
uh mind and i hope i hope that uh i can
persuade you if you
voted in favor of the resolution to
begin with
first of all i i don't think we should
call these
uh measures that we're taking against
the coronavirus pandemic as
lockdowns i think calling them lockdowns
was a horrendous blunder
uh from the get-go and i have stopped
using that word
i i will refer to them as public health
orders and i hope
i don't slip up and refer to them by any
other name during the rest of this
debate
but if i if i do um it's just because
that word has entered the public
discourse so much
and uh i uh
i think public health orders are are the
the way we should describe these uh
these uh what we're doing now
why are public health orders necessary
temporary public health orders necessary
to combat
covid19 there's a lot of
misunderstanding in the public discourse
about
the risks of covert 19
and my interlocutor referred uh in fact
to risk communication as being
a key area there has been a lot of
debate
from the early days of this pandemic
of comparing covet 19 mortality rates to
those of influenza which is a disease
with which we're all familiar so it's
kind of a natural
uh mild post a natural comparison
and i will concede that
uh the infection fatality rate for
coronavirus
is in the same ballpark as that of
influenza
it is in fact a little bit higher it's a
it's about
two or two and a half times higher uh
than
that of flu with the exception of
children in which in which case flu has
a much higher
uh infection fatality rate um but
fatality rates uh by age often
go with uh logarithmic scale so a two
times
uh factor is actually sort of still in
the same ballpark as flu and
so i will readily concede that the
infection fatality rate of coronavirus
is not
a wholesale greater than flu but there
is a complete misunderstanding
of that statistic as it applies to the
risk
it poses for us in the pandemic and one
of my greatest regrets
is that it's not more widely understood
that the ifr the infection fatality rate
is not the key
metric to understand this pandemic and
and in fact some of the debates um
that have been emerging about um oh you
know
it's the same as flu or so-and-so was
right all along or the
is are just which have kind of just
descended really into pure isle uh
name-calling at some points uh really
just it
misunderstands the importance of the
immuno narrativity of
the human population to sars code v2
there are more people who will be
infected with sars code v2 in
the 24 months or so that will represent
the emergent phase of the
stars of the covid pandemic than are
infected
in a flu season or even two flu seasons
it's because the human population is
immuno naive
to sars code v2 now you may say well
there's some
you know cross reactivity with previous
coronaviruses that may be but
more people will become infected with
covid19
in the 24 months of the emergent phase
of the pandemic
than are infected with flu in one or two
flu seasons
so this is very serious health crisis
that will kill
a lot of people it doesn't matter if the
infection fatality rate
is only two times higher than flu it
doesn't matter if the infection fatality
rate is the same as flu
it is more dangerous this is a more
dangerous
virus right now on planet earth than flu
and that is uh important this is a very
severe crisis
and we need to treat it as such
now the great barrington declaration and
the uh
the position laid out by uh my opponent
is is that we need to protect the
vulnerable
and let everyone else get on with
society therefore
thereby improving their quality of life
relative to
adhering to public health orders
we need to follow what's proven to work
protecting the vulnerable does not work
the great barrington declaration does
not go into any detail
about how we will protect the vulnerable
and the fact of the matter is it's a
great idea on paper
i would be on the opposite side of this
debate
if it had any prospect of working
protecting the vulnerable
hasn't worked in any
country and it will not work in the
united states it will not work in
western europe it does not work
most ideas it's a good idea but most
ideas fail and this
is failing the world is full of great
ideas
that we're all familiar with because of
survivorship bias
the good ideas persist the failures
are relegated to the slag heap of
history
the only magic bullet tech solution
that's going to get us out of this
pandemic is
is the vaccine and thank goodness the
vaccine is on the way
the fact that the vaccine is on the way
and as we speak is being distributed
is it's all the proof you need that we
just need to adhere to these public
health orders for a little bit while
longer
there is a pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow we will get through this
and there is no magic bullet it's going
to take a lot of hard work
and the vaccine to get us out
of uh of the um
pandemic the question is not
you know is it a good idea to protect
the vulnerable
it it is in theory one of my favorite
aphorisms is that
in theory there is no difference between
theory and practice but in practice
there is these ideas of protecting the
vulnerable will not work
in practice in part because it is hard a
priori
to identify everyone who is vulnerable
it it just it's a great idea it just
it's just it's not working
and it won't work in the real world we
need
ideas that will work 26
of all the coveted deaths in the county
in which i live which is the sixth most
populous county in the united states
are among individuals younger than age
65.
this is not exclusively a problem
of older people we cannot predict
who will have a severe mortality
from covid the death rates in the united
states among communities of color
are double that among the white
population
this is not just an age issue
this is a race and ethnicity issue and a
class
issue and
it's not a question of protecting
professional people as as my opponent
said and
hurting working-class people the
non-adherence to lockdowns well i said i
wasn't going to use that term
non-adherence to public health orders
does as much damage to
working-class people as
anything else in this pandemic so let me
give you an example the latino
population of orange county california
where i live
is highly
impacted disproportionately to their
population
a lot of people in the latino community
in orange county work in the service
industry
where they have to come to restaurants
and be
front of house staff in the restaurants
interacting with
patrons who are unmasked a patron spends
45 minutes in a restaurant a a waiter or
waitress spends all day in the
restaurant
and then goes home to a less affluent
community at night
this exposure
increases the risk of the working person
and so we cannot always predict
who the vulnerable are 26 of the
mortality where i live
is among people less than 65 and it's
uh it's it's really um
you that that's represent that's similar
it's repeated similarly in communities
across the united states and across the
world
and we're talking about real excess
mortality here
the united states will see 10 more
deaths
this year than we would have expected
for 2020 and these are genuine deaths
this this is not a reassortment of uh
you know people are dying of covet who
would have died of heart disease which
is an argument we hear
all the time these this is we're not
robbing peter to pay paul
deaths are increasing
what we really need
is better fiscal policy to help those
who are impacted so
uh small business owners who own a
restaurant say and people who work in
the restaurant
who are impacted by public health orders
need to receive assistance to get them
through
this crisis and this is something we've
done before
we did more for fiscal policy in the in
the aftermath of the 20th
2008 five minutes five minutes yeah
and we did more in the aftermath of the
2008 crisis than we are doing now
and that is unconscionable
and if you look at the countries that
have uh
been some of the brightest lights like
south korea
the surveillance regime that the south
koreans have been following
is positively draconian by american
standards and
is something that would not fly here
and so if we cannot do
that kind of surveillance and it will
not work and again
we need ideas that will work not just on
a piece of paper but will work in the
real world
given the lack of cooperation we're
seeing with contact tracers in the
united states
that we can i can assure you that the
south korean
scenario will not work here and so
what we need is for us all to make
temporary changes
to our life not going out to restaurants
for a few more months we can still order
takeout
so someone else can still prepare our
food if that's that's our choice
and that is how we will get
through this pandemic
the mortality that we're seeing
uh is substantial it's it's at all ages
except for
childhood ages and the
my opponent today and my and people who
share his views are very clear
on what they perceive are the dangers of
what they are characterizing as a
lockdown
but very uh
evasive about the real mortality and
real dangers that kovid19
is uh posing
to us now the postulates about uh how
scarred
children will be from from doing hybrid
schooling or having to wear a mask at
school
are absolutely hyperbolic and we do not
know the future
and uh i would say the children also
benefit from having their grandparents
around
for a while so uh
we you know it's we need to do
what works we gained 30 years of life
expectancy in
the united states in the 20th century by
doing public health programs that worked
uh not by targeting only the
um those at risk
and that's what we need to do
now and uh i'll have i'll have more to
say
i guess in the in the rebuttal stage but
i
i just really want to summarize my
central argument that protecting the
vulnerable sounds great as a homily
it sounds like yes of course why you
know why aren't we doing
this but there it's it doesn't work in
practice
we cannot predict who will uh who will
die
who will get a severe case of covet
there's so many examples of healthcare
workers who are in their 20s and 30s
who have died from covet and other
people
in that those age groups who have died
from covet
and the uh the thousand times um
difference by age in covid mortality
rates is completely orthogonal all
mortality changes by a factor of a
thousand over age
the point is that covert risks for
younger people are
real and they are a real multiplier one
minute of
of the mortality that we normally see
this is the greatest public health
crisis
of in 100 years since the 1918 flu
it's certainly the worst pandemic of any
uh acute infectious disease that we've
seen since the 1918 flu
and we need to act
temporarily to get through this thank
you
thank you uh andrew uh well that
concludes the initial
presentations we now go to five minutes
of rebuttal
from each side uh take it away martin
your five minutes of rebuttal uh thank
you so uh
we agree that uh kovi 19 is a very
serious issue in a serious disease
so so that is good in terms of
protection in in a pandemic you can
never protect anybody a hundred percent
and uh there are a few people not that
many who argue for a cyril covey to try
to sort of
completely suppress it but that's
unrealistic and that will actually lead
to more just
so we cannot we cannot protect everybody
a hundred percent
no matter how lower risk high risk they
have but we have shown actually
that we have been able to protect the
fluent
at the expense of the lesser fluent for
example if you look at
a graph from toronto they saw that the
motel
that the cases went up equally in the
high effluent and less affluent
neighborhoods but then when you did the
lockdown in toronto on march 23 they
diverged and the high
effluent the fluent neighborhoods sort
of
went uh straight and then down while the
less affluent neighborhood is went still
up for a half up and then had a big big
peak
so we have successfully protected the
fluent members of society
and likewise it is possible to protect
older people we have failed to do so
certainly so i agree with
andrew about that but it is possible and
in the great parenting declaration we
lay out a number of ways to do that
both in the declaration itself but then
more details in the faq
for example in nursing homes which is
the most vulnerable
we need to frequently test all the staff
and we need to
test all the visitors there are still
nursing homes
where they do not test the staff
regularly
and to me that's a scandal
we need to minimize staff rotation so
that arrested into the nursing home
are exposed to a few people as possible
and we should not have any staff working
in more than one nursing home we still
have nursing homes
or nursing home staff who work in more
than one nursing home
and that is also very dangerous
so there are there are examples of
countries who have done well protecting
the nursing homes for example norway
so it is possible if we want to do it
and if we take the measures that are
needed to do it
another thing that we can protect
when i go to the supermarket i see older
people there
and uh it's important for older people
to be outside and exercise and see
see family and grandchildren and so on
but maybe a supermarket is not
high on their on their wish list of what
they absolutely have to do
so we should allow them to have their
groceries delivered to them
uh that's very important and then of
course when they
do see other people they should be happy
to have a in-home test that you don't
have to go
you can just sort of over-the-counter
testing that you can do yourself
uh that can help deciding uh
testing when you have visitors also
andrew talked about the takeout well
there are people in those restaurants
who work as a chef
who are in the 60s 60s and they're
exposed to other people so they are at
risk
to provide the take out food that
we who are working at home can enjoy
so what we need to do is people are over
60
they should not have to work if they can
work from home great
if they're a teacher they should not be
in school they should work from home
with online teaching
or they can help other teachers with
homework creating homeworks or exams
and if that's not possible we should let
them take a
few months of a sabbatical during the
height of transmission using for example
disability insurance or social security
as a temporary measure
and that's very feasible to do and it's
nothing we have tried
one minute one minute another example is
for protecting the elderly we have taken
college students
who hang out who normally would be at
the university
and send them home to their parents
which are maybe in their 50s and 60s or
even older
so by doing that we are increasing the
intergenerational mixing
and that puts older people at risk it's
better if they are at the universities
where they infect other people
that are young in case they get infected
so there are many things that we
could have done and that we still can do
to protect the old high-risk people
and now we soon have one more thing
which is the vaccine
which is another perfect tool for focus
protection
in terms of two things one is to
vaccinate older people at higher risk
and two the second the another priority
is to
vaccinate caretakers of all people
nursing home staff
and the hospital staff working with
geriatric patients
so there certainly is many things that
we could have done to protect elders
that we didn't do
it wouldn't have protected 100 but we
could have done a lot more better and
saved many lives if we had used those
public health public health orders
uh thank you uh and andrew five minutes
of rebuttal take it away andrew
thank you i have a number of points of
disagreement with my
interlocutor and i will do my best to
fit them all into into
five minutes um but uh
so i mean one of the things
that uh martin said just now about
seeing people at the supermarket really
emphasizes
uh in fact that my original point that
calling what we are doing now
a lockdown is really inappropriate these
are public health orders
and uh here in california even under my
stay at home order
i can go for a walk anytime i want i can
go
to an essential business any any time i
want
i can go to the hardware store i can go
to the grocery store
you know i can i can do lots of things
my individual freedoms
aren't really um curtailed now i know
you're uh many people are probably
thinking well
that's because i don't work in uh in a
movie theater and which has been you
know shuttered or whatever but
uh i mean i mean that only speaks to uh
speaks to the point i think in which
martin and i both agree
that uh that we need to use uh
fiscal policy to help make whole people
who who are
impacted i mean he said to use social
security or or
other forms of social insurance
but uh that is something that we haven't
been doing
and it's uh it's it's really uh
a pity that uh that we haven't been
using fiscal policy to help
people get through this and we have an
eviction crisis and
and so on and it's it's really uh
you know that would be perhaps an area
of agreement between the two of us but
in
in any case uh it uh it just shows that
um that you know we need to do more on
that on that side
now as far as the public health orders
uh protecting the affluent uh
i i disagree i mean
we know i mean those of us who study
pandemics we we know that pandemics
are inequality accelerators and that is
you know part of the reason why
pandemics are so bad but
uh these health shocks at the population
level
uh never affect rich and poor alike
and this pin covet pandemic is not
affecting rich and poor like
and to to lay that at the feet of
the public health orders is is not fair
in fact
one of the things that i find so um
that i disagree with so much in the
public discourse is that everything bad
that's happening
is laid at the feet of uh the so-called
lockdowns
and none of it is laid at the feet of
you know the fact that we're in the
worst pandemic in 100 years
um you know the fact that there's uh you
know that there are demand shocks for
certain services and goods
uh has as much to do with the pandemic
as it does
with uh any public health orders uh i i
agree that uh
long-term care facility uh policy has
been
handled in in many cases extremely
poorly and again that
is perhaps another point of agreement
between martin and i
but we're we're almost a year into this
pandemic in in the united states and and
europe and
if if we haven't found the um
you know the special sauce to keep uh
nursing homes protected
by now uh i don't understand how we can
assume that uh
um you know that we're just gonna do
that
overnight i mean i mean i mean the um
you know the idea is we're just gonna
hyper protect uh the vulnerable
who as i've said several times we cannot
predict who they all are and include
many younger people but uh the idea that
we're going to replace
uh public health orders with with the
targeted
um protection of long-term care
facilities in long-term care facilities
protection is uh part of public health
orders now but it's just not
uh working very well and it's uh it's
because things
as i've said don't always go to plan and
it's it's gonna get when to win it's
going to go even worse to plan
if we adopt the great barrington
declaration as our governing
principle of uh
of uh of how we move forward the
the opponents of public health orders
are very certain that every thing that's
bad
is due to the public health orders and
none of it is due to the pandemic
and typically very dismissive of the
real risks that the pandemic causes
and focusing on the infection fatality
rate when
as i said that is not the most important
statistic it's the immune naive nature
of the population so
there's just um
i mean i have so many fundamental
differences with the great barrington
declaration
and we will get through this
and we need to keep protecting everyone
in society
because we are all stakeholders in a
society thank you
uh andrew that concludes the initial
presentation and rebuttal
portion of the evening we now go to the
q and a
portion and uh uh let me just
reset and uh uh i've got a couple of
questions coming in
for you andrew maybe i could ask some
well
let me focus on this one uh it begins
with a statement that
uh citing data that 94
of those people who die of covert 19
have an underlying condition have a
co-morbidity
and so um wouldn't that be an identifier
of the vulnerable
and so if you do have a comorbidity you
are vulnerable
because 94 of those who die of covet are
vulnerable in terms of a comorbidity and
since you
uh endorse uh martin caldwell's
idea of social security of fiscal policy
helping people
wouldn't that be a marker in order to
protect
the vulnerable uh
that's a great question as as is so
often the case in
in in this um debate and in the larger
public discourse around kobe 19
there are statements made which don't
have uh any kind of comparison group
death certificates have uh an underlying
cause and they have
uh many entries for contributory causes
you can have 15 or more
contributory causes on a death
certificate and it's not uncommon
to see multiple causes of death with
with one being nominated as the
underlying cause
and so comorbidities are a fact of life
they're a fact of life
in in in normal pre-pandemic and
life they will be effective life in
post-pandemic life so the fact that
there are comorbidities in covid really
doesn't differentiate it from other
causes of death and moreover the
comorbidities that have often been cited
as
being really salient for example
diabetes and hypertension
and obesity are
you know things that people live with
for decades i mean hypertension is is
very
often in many cases in most cases
well managed by a modern uh therapies
and uh you know uh obesity does not
shave uh 30 years off of life expectancy
so
uh so we're the people who die are dying
with comorbidities that
that you know that they could live with
for for decades
so uh it's really the covid that
is the issue and and uh i i don't
foresee
um using data on
people who've died so far to protect
those who are still living
as a viable option
i'm sorry well okay the focus not a
viable option
but then the question is why is it you
said that it's it's impossible to
identify the vulnerable
so the focus here is the the objective
identifier of the vulnerable would be to
say that
if you have a comorbidity you are
vulnerable so wouldn't that be a
reasonably objective identifier of the
vulnerable
given that you said we can't identify
the vulnerable but can't we
since 94 of them have co-morbidities
wouldn't that be the focus of the
question
and i mean what percentage of the u.s
population has has some sort of
co-morbidity i mean these things are all
uh always obvious after the fact but uh
i mean obesity and hypertension are
extremely prevalent
as is type 2 diabetes so uh
again uh it sounds great but it's it's
not
practical in my opinion martin you want
to address that question
uh as well yes so there are common
abilities that increases risk
of uh covering 19 mortality
but age is by far the biggest risk
factor
uh is an enormous difference at risk as
i said more than a thousand four between
the oldest and the youngest
so anybody who is above 60
should consider themselves to be in a
high-risk group and of course
if you're older than that even more so
but uh
if you have coherences like andrew was
saying for example diabetes or obesity
that also increases your risk
and i don't know the exact thing but i
think having those
type of communities is equivalent to
about five years in age
so if you're in your 50s and you have
diabetes or you're obese
i think you should also be very very
careful
okay uh another question for you
andrew relating to uh the argument
that martin was making with respect to
the schools uh
arguing citing data that zero deaths
occurred in sweden
and then stipulating that that
vulnerable teachers who
might be exempted but a question would
you lift
uh the public health measures as you
call them with respect
to the schools so uh
first of all i i don't expect any uh
childhood deaths in in in a country as
small as sweden
for reasons that we have both talked
about i mean that covert 19 is unlike
flu in that it doesn't kill
children i mean and that's just that's
why you have no deaths in sweden
from kids because uh it
the death rates are extremely low uh ex
extremely extremely extremely low for
children from covered 19 i mean that's
an area
where i think martin and i probably
agree the most i think
uh schools uh you know but sweden
uh i mean i don't want to make this uh
you know
about sweden um necessarily but uh
you know sweden has done worse than its
neighbors norway and finland for example
so i mean i don't i don't see
you know why we need to uh keep sort of
fetishizing sweden
in the in the debate um but the uh
the question about schools is a good one
and i unders and and i know that
people in the audience have very strong
opinions about schools
you know i think schools can carefully
uh continue to be
running in person and
certainly more primary schools than high
schools
and high schools need to be watched very
carefully
and we're you know we're debating public
health orders
or if you insist on calling them you
know lockdowns then
fine but uh the and i don't uh
so this is not a debate about schools
exclusively and
i i don't want to see bars and
nightclubs open and schools closed that
is absolutely perverse
i want to see bars and nightclubs and
restaurants for in-person dining
close before we close schools
in some circumstances it you know some
communities have
seen fit to include uh distance learning
uh you know for for uh for
kids and uh you know it's it's probably
a very
uh worthy debate to have as to how
effective you know if you're in the
second grade
how effective zoom instruction is and
it's not something that anyone wants to
see
i i do think that uh you know the ram
the remedies
uh you know we may have to experiment
with uh
doing a 13th year of uh primary and
secondary education for some cohorts
to make up for uh this disruption which
again is a disruption caused
as much by the pandemic as it is by any
public health order and also
you know uh we're extrapolating from uh
studies in the past of kids who have uh
missed a year of education or something
like that where where everyone around
them has had that year of education and
then we're saying see well look
how terrible it is if you know and look
at your future job market outcomes if
you
if you lose out on education but when an
entire cohort
has the same effect you know there are
ways that we can remedy it such that
uh the comparative disadvantage will be
will be lessened so i mean
there's all sorts of doom and gloom
extrapolation from very limited data
about you know the scarring that these
uh children will
will impact will have and i i i believe
uh the other side is being overconfident
in uh
predicting the future 30 years from now
in terms of the outcomes of these
these children well okay but if i did
hear you correctly you seem to indicate
that you would
uh rescind the public health orders that
have
shut down or partially shut down the
schools at least up to perhaps the uh uh
up to the element up to the high school
level uh is that right
i mean only if everything else is uh
hasn't already been tried i mean i don't
i don't want to see schools uh
schools closed but not uh
but uh bars and nightclubs open but i
so i mean i i think in many cases
schools can remain open at least for
elementary but
to me it's not uh beyond
scope to allow certain jurisdictions to
say that we're going to do
uh zoom education you know uh for
for schools at least uh temporarily but
i mean it needs to be approached on a
case-by-case basis i
schools are the most important you know
in social institution in society
and they should be closed last and
opened first
okay thank you martin do you want to
comment on that question and uh
andrew's response uh yes so uh
in focus protection the two things that
in my view is the most important if i
could only pick two things one
is to open all the schools for in-person
teaching
and they open in some parts of the
country but there are many
kids who are not getting
in-person teaching and
that is of course affecting the working
class the most working classroom the
most because
children of of more affluent parents
they can arrange a tutor or post
schooling or some i know some people
have sent their
kids to private school when their public
schools closed so
this is something that's very tragic for
working class children especially but of
course for all children as well so i'm
very happy to hear that andrew
is also sort of prioritizing keeping
schools open for in-person teaching
the other priority of the great
barrington declaration is to do a better
job
with uh nursing home residents since
they
are the most vulnerable so i also very
much appreciate that andrew
uh acknowledges that we have not done as
good a job as we could with that
and that we need to do a better job so
uh so there's certainly
uh is areas of the agreement between
me and andrew so i think that's very
nice uh okay
uh now question for uh you martin
uh having to do with andrew's
statement about uh people being immune
immuno naive
um which uh has interpreted to being
then
that the idea of hurt immunity
the idea that uh we we have in any ca in
in some cases or could in many cases
achieve herd immunity where
fifty percent of the population are
immune uh
mar uh andrew seems to be saying that
that's not really achievable uh and so
this is of course a
an issue of your different scientific
perceptions
immuno naivete we're immuno naive
that's what he says and could you
respond
to that statement on andrew's part well
he is correct that that is
that this is a new virus or which many
people
do not have immunity
for some reason children seem to be
handling it very well
and when there's probably some cross
immunity from other coronaries
and that's probably what's explaining
the law mortality in japan for example
what could be one of the reasons there
but i mean
there is we are naive to this and that's
why it's a pandemic
uh and i agree with him that the
infection fatality ratio is not
the only thing that we need to compare
because it's also the number of people
who actually get infected
uh that's a key issue in terms of how
seal is so
on those sort of uh at numerical things
there's complete agreement i think
between us
well you have mentioned uh in the uh
declaration heard immunity
are you basically saying then that uh
herd immunity
is not likely in this case uh
no i mean on the on the contrary we will
reach her immunity or whatever strategy
we use
so whether we do lock downs or focus
protections or whatever we do
we will eventually reach her immunity
because that's the scientific
established phenomena just like gravity
is in physics
so it's like if you're an airplane if
you know airplane
you will gravity will eventually ensure
that you do hit the ground
no matter what you do how you fly the
airplane so the key
thing is how do we minimize mortality
until we reach her immunity and her
immunity
can be reached through either natural
infection
or from vaccines or what's going to
happen for kova 19
with the combination of the two and uh
well that because
that actually gives rise to the other
question andrew has
said we do have the vaccines uh
developed
they are being delivered uh would you uh
then say that uh logically then we
should
wait for the vaccines uh to be uh
dispensed
so that we can achieve hurt immunity and
then continue the
the public health orders that he favors
should we do that and wait for that
vaccines to bring her to immunity
so when we have a vaccine now we still
don't know
very much about it but we know that it
reduces uh
symptoms in in in adults
up to about age 70 or so we don't know
how it affects mortality we don't know
how to fix transmission yet
but what we need to do with the vaccine
is to use it as a tool for focus
protection
to vaccinate people in nursing homes for
example that's the top priority
to vaccinate geriatric patients in
hospitals
also to vaccinate the older population
in general
as well as which is also important to
vaccinate uh
staff members staff at nursing homes
uh and uh people working in hospitals
through taking care of all people there
so we can use vaccines as one additional
tool
in doing focus protection
but um we should not only rely on that
we have to continue we have to still do
a better job
testing nursing home style for example
and there is absolutely no reason to
keep school
closed way closed uh waiting for for the
vaccine
and with the vaccine coming that's just
one more
argument i think for opening our schools
for in-person teaching
um andrew uh do you want to comment then
on those questions that on uh
uh martin's yeah yeah let me make two
quick points
uh thank you thank you gene uh first of
all the the
the point i made about immuno naivete uh
it's basically in service of the idea
that we shouldn't worship the ifr the
infection fatality rate
being relatively low uh that's not
what's important about covet
but we're immuno naive at the start of
the pandemic but we won't be immuno
naive at the end of the pinpoint so when
i use this term immuno naive
i don't mean to imply that herd immunity
is impossible indeed uh
as as martin said herd immunity is the
outcome uh
no matter what i mean the end game is
i think we both agree it's hurt immunity
i think we're we're we're debating
uh uh how we get there and martin and i
have uh
have quite different uh visions of how
uh
the road work looks from here to hurt
immunity but herd immunity is the
outcome
my comments about immuno naivety were to
sort of discount
this uh continual drum beat of
the ifr now let me make one other quick
point uh
the vaccine is the piece of tech that's
most important here and
i'm certainly looking forward to getting
my vaccination and uh
obviously i'm i'm i'm low down the list
because uh
people like nursing home staff uh should
be prioritized and i agree
100 there with martin but uh
we still don't and i hate to be sort of
a little bit glass half empty all the
time but we
we still don't know um if this is a
transmission blocking vaccine or
or simply if it reduces uh symptoms so
we know that the vaccine is going to do
us a lot of good and it's going to drop
mortality down
but we we're not 100 sure yet whether
people who are vaccinated
whether whether they are absolutely
sterile have sterilizing immunity and
are completely
invulnerable to infection or if they
simply get a
much much much much milder case of covid
when they are exposed to the virus and
and therefore there's still a
possibility that they can shed virus
so vaccinating a nursing home staff
member well
well certainly appropriate uh does not
mean
that that nursing home staff member
doesn't still need to mask
when uh she is on duty at the nursing
home uh because we're not 100
sure that she cannot shed virus uh
asymptomatically
even post-vaccination and this is
exactly why
we need to keep up the public health
orders
so so as to reduce the community
transmission
so that even a vaccinated nursing home
staff member doesn't
acquire um infection
going to the movie theater or or
something like that
until it's safe to do so because uh
this vaccine could render infections to
be asymptomatic rather than preventing
them entirely
but that doesn't uh entirely reduce the
transmission to zero so
there's a lot of tricky nuance here but
i i do agree with martin
that uh in the as we come up with
priorities of who gets vaccine first
that a nursing home staff member should
be high up the list
getting a number of questions about the
public health
measures andrew i guess one
in particular is where is your
end game at what point
uh given that you even seem to be
expressing doubts about the vaccine
at what point would you lift
the public health measures that you
favor
what what has to happen before you say
let's end it
and how many months is that going to
likely to take
uh that's a great question and uh my
vision for these public health orders is
that they're temporary
and uh you know uh
over the summer we saw a transmission go
down in many local
locales that had had a spring wave and
the key is to get the trans uh the
effective reproductive number well below
one
and that means you know that each case
on average is producing less than one
new case and we're not going to
eradicate covet
i mean there's all sorts of pie in the
sky stuff about
covid zero and uh i mean covet is most
likely gonna become
an another seasonal like flu-like
illness that kind of
is just sort of in the in the background
we we have
uh four coronavirus strains that
circulate
uh worldwide now that cause the common
cold in the wintertime
and this will likely in in years or
decades become like the fifth such
syndrome that it'll just be it'll be
there where the genie is out of the
bottle uncovered we're not going to
eradicate it
i mean my anticipation with the between
the vaccine
and seasonal effects and people you know
getting to hurt immunity the hard way my
anticipation would be that summer of
2021 in the northern hemisphere
will be essentially a normal summer uh
in terms of restrictions but uh the
answer is
when cases come down and and the
effective reproductive number is
significantly below one
then we can start to to lift public
health orders it's certainly not
nothing nothing that i envision us doing
uh indefinitely and and not because i
expect us to eradicate kovit
i i just think you know we're in the
emergent phase now
and this is the first winter in which
the northern hemisphere
starts the winter with kovid on the
ground and and therefore
even though people are already exhausted
from all of this it's really
still early days
uh comment from you martin on that
yeah andrew is correct that this virus
is going to become endemic
but the nature of it is actually quite
promising for the future because
what's what happens is when you have an
endemic you get new people are born
and of course they don't have immunity
and then they will be exposed but they
will be exposed as children and for
children this is not a serious uh
virus so it's going to be with us for
many decades but most people
are going to be exposed when they are
children
and then they're going to build up the
immunity so i think the long-term
uh prospects of this disease is actually
quite favorable
where that and when i first heard about
about uh kovit in ruhan i sort of
quickly uh
tried to figure out about it and it was
it was uh it was immediately obvious
that this was gonna be a pandemic
that's gonna tour the whole world that
it was impossible to keep it out
from from sort of hitting most parts of
the world
at the same time as a parent you're
always mostly concerned about your
children and i have three kids
ages five five and 18. and
after being worried about 10 minutes i
could clearly see that this is not a
dangerous thing for children so my
children will be fine
thank you a question for you andrew and
uh
from martin as well but let's start with
you andrew uh basically uh
uh the questions have to do with
toting up on one side of the ledger
those who likely have been have died
from
the public health measures and the focus
of many
is that the unseen especially is that
because of
recessions in the rich countries of the
world a lot of people are starving in
the poor countries
so there's an enormous amount of death
uh attributable to that
to the recessions that the that the uh
public health measures have caused
and uh so that seems to be a big number
uh as many argue and then uh and then
you
you speak of all the deaths that have
occurred even though we've had public
health orders
so then you have to presumably focus on
the deaths that have been prevented
because of the public health orders and
i guess further so many other questions
are
what evidence do you have that the
public health orders have made much a
difference much of a difference
we have such so much so many different
public health orders
in different states and difficulty
showing any difference in deaths
so that's a long question but the the
short
version of it is how many how many lives
have been saved by the public
health orders and how many in your view
including
looking globally uh in the in the poor
countries of the world
how many lives have been lost well this
is a very multi-dimensional question
and uh but i mean the if we look at the
mortality in the united states i'll get
to the world in
in a minute but if we look at mortality
in the united states uh
i mean if you look at the excess deaths
in the united states in
with a painting with a broad brush
stroke here uh in 2020
you know the deaths that are over and
beyond what we would expect at this
stage
in the year based on you know the pretty
regular
patterns of mortality in previous years
uh the number of deaths we've had
uh about three hundred thousand you know
maps pretty well on to
uh the the the the excess deaths so that
the deaths that have been counted as
covid deaths because it's a good faith
determination of
of a health care provider that this
person died of covet are mapping pretty
well onto
i mean not perfectly but pretty well on
to the the excess deaths that we've seen
and so i mean i i i think that
th this idea that i'm i'm confident in
fact it's this idea that that public
health measures are causing
other other deaths is is going to be
uh shown to be minimal in its effect
and it's and it's not just public health
orders that cause deaths
it's the pandemic i mean i mean
hospitals
in orange county are over where i live
are overflowing
with covet patients right now and the
director of ems of the county
has advised hospitals to postpone
elective surgeries
that is not because of the public health
orders that is because of the pandemic
and it's true
that in the absence of a vaccine
if we just run the clock for 25 years
with kovid
sooner or later everyone will will will
get it
and the idea of these interventions is
to flex
to flatten the curve so that we don't
crush the hospitals at any given point
in time
but the area under that curve whether
it's steep or whether it's flat
is 100 of a population or
70 of the population or whatever but we
we've seen for example in the dakotas
where uh
the government took a very light touch
to
to to interventions we see the highest
um infection rates and very high
uh mortality rates compared to other
states that have
been more proactive so and given that
the
uh vaccine is on our doorstep
um you know it really makes
all the more sense just to steal
ourselves for a few more months of
adherence to orders
and then we can start to you know get
mortality under control
as far as uh children starving to death
in developing countries
i mean uh that's a very uh stark
uh that paints a very stark picture but
the reality on the ground is much more
complicated than that
i mean when when you look at mortality
statistics
uh in many countries are still
a lot of guesswork and uh there's i mean
people in my profession of demography
spend a lot of time trying to estimate
mortality
statistics from different regions
i i truly believe that that these
accounts will be
shown to be exaggerations uh and i
haven't seen anything reliable that
suggests that there's wholesale famine
mortality in the developing world
at the moment much less caused by
kovid 19 recessions in uh
north america and europe
just let me rephrase that question just
briefly that
that uh with respect to uh the lives
saved from
the protective health measures um you
cite
all the deaths that have occurred and
yet we've had protective health
orders so uh do you think that a
substantial do you think that
you know florida has been contrasted
florida's doesn't have a whole lot of
effective health measures has a lot of
old people who are vulnerable
uh south dakota do you think that
there's overwhelming evidence that
hundreds of thousands of lives have been
saved from the protective health orders
that are not hundreds of that triple
double the number of deaths
if we did not have the public health
orders well
first of all hundreds of thousands of
lives no second of all
uh the the united states has been
absolutely abysmal in adherence to
these public health orders i mean uh
there's a public health order
uh here in california and uh a number of
restaurants have have been just openly
said that they're going to
uh defied these orders and uh
so you know uh i mean
uh so i it's it's very hard to quantify
um you know in the middle of things
what the impact is of public health
orders especially since
the the most important mortality
statistics are going to be the final
mortality statistics
so i will concede that we are
in a crisis and that it's hard to
measure these outcomes
as the crisis unfolds uh because some
countries
for example shifting for the moment to
north to
to europe some countries that did well
early on have been hammered later on
and so
we need to uh
you know my i'm appealing to to
principles real real
really rather than statistics in terms
of uh
you know doing what we know works for
controlling infection spread and not uh
pursuing an ideal
of uh of targeted protection which
i have asserted that you know does not
work and will not work
thank you uh andrew uh martin uh which
hopefully you'll agree
that uh since we have actually run out
of uh normally a lot of time for the q a
uh you have seven and a half minutes of
your summary
and so if you want to comment on what uh
what andrew has just said
in your summary please do so but let's
uh let's go to the summary portion of
the evening
uh seven and a half minutes for you
martin to sum up your case
please take it away martin uh thank you
so uh i guess one disagreement that we
do have which is big
is the collateral damage
on other health aspects
which i think is enormous
we don't have all the statistics even
because we have very good statistics or
very sort of
uh up-to-date daily weekly statistics on
corey 19 cases socializations mortality
and so on
but a lot of these other the collateral
damage on
cardiovascular health cancers mental
health
and so on is things that we know a
little bit about but
uh uh but something that we will
learn more and more about as as time
goes but we do already know a lot about
it now and uh
there is a website that's very that has
many of these
uh scientific studies on this is called
collateral global so the collateral
global.org
where you can see about effects on
starvation which
once they thought it was ten thousand
children starving to death in the world
every month and that means that there's
also many who are malnutritions which
will have long-term public health
effects uh
tuberculosis has gone up the polio is
worse and so on
uh so there's enormous
[Music]
damage from uh from the lockdowns uh
and uh from uh from people being afraid
to go to the doctor and so on
uh now the great barrington declaration
of focus protection
is nothing something that is uh novel or
fringe
it's in accordance with the many
pandemic preparedness plans that
countries have made up that
in the pandemic you focus your attention
on protecting those at higher risk
it's also something that's not unique to
the three of us who wrote it
there are many people who including the
three of us but many others who back in
march and april was arguing for a focus
protection
using different names age target
strategy etc
a risk-based strategy so
this is nothing novel and there were so
so many people were advocating for that
very early on but the reason you don't
necessarily
realize that is that as we were doing
that
we were
we were not sort of in the media i tried
to publish my thoughts in the u.s but
failed to do so i had no problems
publishing in my native sweden
in the major daily newspapers there but
i was unable to publish anything in
march april in the united states
despite several attempts
so uh i think this has been a very good
and informative
discussion i think i agree with
andrew neumer that this kind of uh
scientific discourse is critical and i'm
uh
also willing to die uh on for it on the
same hill as andrew is doing
uh i'd like to thank eugene and
everybody at soho forum for organizing
this
most of all though i would like to thank
andrew for
for doing this debate and this
discussion
uh and for doing it in such a
logical scientific and polite manner
but most of all for him being willing to
do so i
i did another debate about a month ago a
month debate
and they were unable to get uh any
archaeologist to debate me
so they found a psychologist instead so
there was a good debate
but i really really appreciate uh andrew
for doing this so thank you so much
andrew
all right we is that and that concludes
your summary nothing further
yes that's good thank you all right um
all right andrew you uh you can take
your seven and a half minutes to
summarize uh take it away andrew
thank you gene and thank you martin um
my pleasure to debate you i'll debate
you a
again if you'd like uh as the pandemic
continues to unfold
and i think also as i said to the
audience and
it's so important that we maintain
channels of scholarly
debate because there will be
disagreements
there are differences of opinions among
people who can reasonably uh claim
expertise in in the area and um
you know i hope i've made my case to the
audience
uh we're in the midst of the greatest
infectious disease pandemic
of an acute illness in
over 100 years and we are all
stakeholders in our communities
in our national societies and
in the human population world society
and the way we are going to defeat this
pandemic
is together it is impossible
to target certain people
for protection and to pull it off it's a
great idea
but there are plenty of great ideas that
just don't work
nothing succeeds like success that
historian eh carr said
and the the the world is full of ideas
that we still have
because they were successful this idea
of targeted protection
will not be successful it will be an
abject failure and
uh you know it to the extent to which
the united states is undergoing
um you know really painful throws of
this pandemic right now
is reflected uh
because it's a it's a terrible pandemic
and because we're not really
adhering to public health orders uh i i
agree that
um we should find a solution so that a
60 or year old person or older
uh can have someone to do their shopping
for them
uh and and my interlocutor said that
he sees people in the grocery store who
are elderly doing their own grocery
shopping but
you know we're not funding the fiscal
we're not funding programs that would
that would make that happen
and in absence of that we need to just
lower the temperature of the pandemic we
need to lower the
effective reproductive number by all
contributing to
these public health orders it's an
evidence that the public health orders
aren't being followed that we can all
just go to the supermarket whenever
we want and there's no controls of the
number of people who are admitted in in
most cases
at any given point in time uh
so you know it's it's i know people are
tired of
everything and but what they're tired of
is the pandemic
not the public health orders and
you know the other the other thing i
want to say is that we cannot take
everything bad about the pandemic and
lay it all at the feet
of public health orders and none of it
at the feet of the pandemic itself
that is so intellectually dishonest to
me
we are in a really grave pandemic
and you know the public health orders
are not exacerbating pandemic mortality
and
and i seriously doubt they're
exacerbating non-pandemic mortality in
significant ways
in the net benefit is is is enormous
in terms of cutting down on covet 19
mortality in the community and uh
you know right now where i live we're
experiencing a surge
a hospital surge both in hospital
occupancy
and in the icu and this is caused
by the pandemic this is people
in the hospital with covid19 this is
caused by the pandemic now if someone
cannot receive care for a stroke or a
heart attack
because the icus are full in orange
county and they are
how is that a result of the lockdown
that is the result of the pandemic
we are facing a crisis that crisis is
coveted 19
we need to do what's proven it's it's a
great homily to say we're going to
protect
the vulnerable but the vulnerable
includes far
far more people than just the elderly
includes communities of color and it
includes other people whom we cannot
always predict
26 percent of the destin where i live
are among people younger than age 65.
so i i thank uh again martin you and
everyone who organized this debate and i
thank
the audience for making this debate
happen i hope
um i've changed your mind
and we will all get through this and we
will get through it
using the public health techniques that
expanded life expectancy by 30 years
since the 20th century and those are
take public health approaches
that aim to help everyone not just
a few people those are the ones that
work best those are ones that are proven
and those are the ones that will succeed
thank you
thank you andrew okay so that concludes
uh the debate uh
jane please open the final vote
we have the results and uh
this is oh my gosh wow all right i
i'm going to deliver uh the the punch
line
the punch line is that according to
oxford style voting
it was a tie and uh
but although i'll send you guys the
numbers since of course it's part of the
game it's quite a funny
uh the yes vote on martin's behalf
began at 68.06 percent and went up
it gained 5.56 points went to 73.61
but you were rated on how much you moved
the needle
so martin got an overwhelming majority
however
he went up by 5.56 percent uh the
no vote began at 19.44
and went up to 25 it too gained 5.56
points so it was an even
split and i guess you guys are going to
have to split
the tootsie roll congratulations to you
both and thanks so much for
participating
and see you all hopefully for our next
debate
good evening all